- Say congratulations, 'cause I hear
you have a new man in your life.
- I do.
- That's exciting.
- I know.
- Love is fun.
- It's the best.
It's the best when it's healthy,
(laughs)
you know?
It's really exciting.
- Oh God, it's amazing.
- It's really beautiful, that's us.
- I know, so he's a baseball player,
so did you know a lot
about baseball before?
- My dad had brought me
to baseball games when I was young.
- That means no.
(both laughing)
You're like, "I went to a game."
- [Vanessa] Well, I love basketball.
- Oh yeah, me too.
- I'm very much like
go to the sports ball,
I watch basketball.
More ball.
- Sports ball, that's what I call it.
- Sports ball, sports ball.
But yeah, I've definitely
grown my knowledge in baseball.
I know how the game works now.
- [Kelly] You're one ahead of me.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So wait, so who does he play for again?
- The Pittsburgh Pirates.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's awesome.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- Pirates, I like the...
I like the mascot.
- Yeah, I'm like, "Go Pirates, arr!"
- This is how I vote for things:
on mascot or colors or
this is how I do it.
This is how I did my
bracket for basketball.
- Oh nice, you did a bracket.
- [Kelly] I did.
- That's impressive.
- Well, I...
Okay.
Every single one of my
friends and my sister
they all love frigging sports.
Like every...
I don't know how I ended up in this crew.
I am definitely the black
sheep, but they all love it.
So I did a bracket, I don't know.
- That's impressive.
- It's not.
- They tried to get me to do a bracket
and I was like, "I don't
have time for that."
- Oh my God.
But it's kind of fun when
you start picking teams
for like certain reasons, but
it's not fun when you lose.
Auburn looking at you.
Okay, is there any sport you are good at?
Do you love playing sports?
- I mean...
(laughs breathlessly)
- Oh, that means no.
(laughing)
- Well, Cole is like very sporty.
Does all the sports.
Loves golf, recently got into golfing.
- Golf is fun when you play.
I don't like to watch it.
- And so, yeah,
I've recently gotten into it.
That was actually my very
first time at a driving range.
- [Kelly] They're fun.
- Yeah!
I realized there's nothing better
than that sound of the
(mimics golf ball) tink
when you hit the ball right.
- Yes.
- I'm trying to go get
fitted so I have my own clubs
and then feel like I'm ready
to take on a full course.
- I kind of get it too.
'Cause for forever, I'd just
be like, "that's so boring."
They just leave, like guys who was here,
men leaving and I'm like, "now I get it."
- Now you get it.
- Because you get the
whole freaking day off.
And you're basically just walking around
talking to your buddies.
- Yeah, and you're outside!
- Hitting a ball around being like,
"Yeah I was playing golf."
- You get fresh air.
You're with the trees.
You do it the right time
of day, you get a sunset.
- You get a drink, they
come around with them.
- It's a vibe, I'm into it.
- It is a vibe, I'm into it too.
Women, we need to catch on.
- Maybe we need to go play golf together
is what we're saying.
- We're like, "If you can watch..."
This would be good TV as
well, cause I'm not great.
I'm like Happy Gilmore.
I can get it down, I can
really nail the ball,
but I can't putt for anything.
- [Vanessa] Gotcha.
- Yeah.
- Okay, so maybe, we'll...
I'm great at short distance.
You're great at long distance.
We can just be one player.
- Is that what they call it?
Did I call it something you're
not supposed to call it?
- I honestly have no idea.
- Putting?
Oh, okay.
- No, it is!
Short, putt.
- [Kelly] Putting, right?
- Sports.
(giggles)
- Yeah, so I drink when I play.
So I'm like, "Whatever,
I'm not good at that thing.
Putt Putt Golf whatever."